من اسبوعين تقريبا كنا تناولنا في
برنامجنا قضيه لاعب كره القدم البرازيلي
داني البس اللي اتهم فيها بالاعتداء
الجنسي على فتاه في ملهى ليلي ببرشلونه
واتكلمنا كيف تم القبض عليه مباشره وما
وافق القاضي انه بكفاله وكيف ناديكم
المكسيكي فسخ تعاقد معامن بعد الاتهامات
اللي طالته وكيف تطورت الازمه بسرعه وداني
البس لازال في السجن والربايات اللي قالها
داخل السجن روايات ويعني تغيرت عن الحادثه
تحديدا هذه خلينا نقول انها تغيرت اكثر من
مره في الاول قال ما كان وقت الحادثه في
المكان بعدين رجع قال انه كان مع اصحابه
هناك لكن ما يعرف البنت والعمره شافها
بعدين رجع قال انه يعرفها لكن يومها في
الاخر اقر انه شافها وكان في لقاء في
الحمام لمده 15 دقيقه وصار بينهم شيء يعني
باختصار اعترف باللي قطته الكاميرات لكنه
قال انه اللي صار كان برضا الفتاه اللي
بدورها بتاكد انه هذا الكلام غير صحيح وما
كان في شيء برضائها اليوم في اخبار جديده
عن تفاصيل كفشه كشفها اللاعب المتهم عن
الجريمه وتفاصيلها وهذه التفاصيل يبدو
انها حكمت على زواجه بالنهايه فزوجته
اسمها جوانا سانس واعاده ازياء من
باراغواي كانت في البدايه وقفت معه ونشرت
اكثر من بوست الدعم له وقالت لنا مو مصدق
انه ممكن يعمل شيء مثل هذا الموقف منها
بعد اعترافات داني تحول والاخبار اليوم
بتاكد انها تقدمت رسميا بدعوه طلاق ضد
زوجها بعد ما تم تداول الانباء بشكل واسع
رجعت وطلعت كمان في ستوري على حسابه على
الانستغرام وقالت انه اذا في اي قرار
بيخصها فهي راح تعلن عبر حساباتها يعني لا
نفت ولا اكدت الخبر لكن وسائل الاعلام
بتاكد موضوع الطلاق واللي بياكدوا اكثر
نظره على حسابها اللي اختفى منه كل صورهم
مع بعض الا الصور اللي كانت ضمن اعلانات
او حملات دعائيه مشتركه
[موسيقى]